He said you'd come
now let's hope you're not too late.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie!
this is going to be my new Justice League Snyder
cut video for all the Green Lantern
stuff that Zack Snyder teased the other
day so we'll break it down if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos will do a new Amazon
giveaway too all you have to do to enter
is be subscriber
and let me know what you want to see
from Green Lantern inside the Snyder cut
there's multiple scenes that we know
about so starting with number 5 if you
didn't see the news recently Zack Snyder
confirmed new Green Lantern for the
Justice League Snyder cut he's made
several announcements in the past week
and dropped a lot of teasers for a lot
of different things on his social
accounts Green Lantern is just the
biggest thing that he's been talking
about recently since he announced the
Snyder cut back in May he's been way
more active answering fans questions
about new scenes new footage deleted
scenes characters that weren't in the
theatrical cut like Darkseid the post
that he was referencing when talking
about new Green Lantern stuff was
actually for Hal Jordan and John Stewart
Green Lantern a fan asked him what he
meant by the slogan unite the seven and
if that meant new Green Lantern was
coming in the Snyder cut Zack Snyder
didn't say which Green Lantern but he
did confirm yes yes Green Lantern would
be coming back into the movie we
actually know a lot about the original
plans for green lantern scenes in the
Justice League movies when they were
still going to be doing multiple Justice
League movies because some of the Green
Lantern scenes were setting up the next
movie and one of them was an actual
full-blown post-credit scene there were
a lot of people asking about Ryan
Reynolds becoming the Green Lantern of
the Snyder cut I thought that it was a
joke at first but apparently there's a
real rumor going around that he's in
talks I don't think that that rumor is
true but maybe we'll get him to post
some jokes on his Twitter account when
they released the Snyder cut next year
please don't make the supersuit green or
animated so number four the Green
Lantern scenes that we know about
originally according to Kevin Smith when
he was talking to visual effects people
who worked on the movie the first Green
Lantern scenes were always going to be
in the big flashback Dark Side war scene
technically at this point he hasn't
become dark side yet his name is still
exhaust and that's why he looks like
this instead of like comic book dark
side he only became dark side and took
that name when he killed his brother and
took the Omega for its power from him
that's where he gets his Omega beams
ability but during the version of this
scene that you see in
Justice League Snyder cut trailer that
they dropped a little while ago visual
effects artists speaking anonymously
after the movie came out claimed that
they were actually going to be two Green
Lantern's during this big fight scene
the theatrical cut only had one Green
Lantern his name is younger he is
comic-book accurate in the comics he was
the Green Lantern of this sector of
space thousands of years ago so that's
why his acts Nider put him in the movie
but the visual effects artist didn't
specify who the second ancient Green
Lantern was supposed to be the story
behind Gallagher is actually pretty cool
when he died his body was still so
powerful that the Green Lantern Corps
took it back to OA in the Owens
incorporated it into the star heart an
experimental weapon that then later
became Alan Scott's Green Lantern
battery when he was part of the Justice
Society if you haven't been watching the
DC TV shows they're actually doing a
version of this storyline on the star
girl TV show right now with Alan Scott's
Green Lantern battery but they haven't
revealed the new Green Lantern yet
number three there are some conflicting
reports about the next two green lantern
scenes in the Snyder cut and who those
Green Lantern's would have been so
according to Kevin Smith when Justice
League was still supposed to be a
trilogy of movies
there were visit X plates that they had
set up for a Green Lantern scene in this
moment here this deleted scene is of
Superman visiting Alfred before he goes
to join the rest of the Justice League
to fight Steppenwolf
I'm assuming your Alford master Kent
you said you'd come
now that's hope no too late but
according to Kevin Smith in these visits
artists at one point this was going to
be a Hal Jordan Green Lantern scene
where he shows up and then joins the
team because it's all about unites the
seven like sex liners confirming in his
post they will unite the seven members
of the Justice League during the movie
that might be why in the early trailers
there was still a glint of green in his
eyes there and maybe they changed the
scene to a Superman scene either later
in the process when it stopped being a
trilogy of Justice League movies and
they just decided to push a lot of the
Green Lantern stuff into the second
movie or maybe it was Joss Whedon that
got rid of all the Green Lantern stuff
that's why a lot of those early trailers
have so many deleted scenes in them all
of that is Zack Snyder footage that
we're going to see in the Snyder cut number
two the other report was that there was
an entire alternate post-credit scene
for the movie that featured two alien
Green Lantern's coming to earth so
according to the same visual effects
artist who worked on the movie it was
supposed to be Kilowog in tomar a coming
to meet Batman at his house by the lake
this was still when there would have
been a Justice League 2 that featured
them fighting Darkseid directly so the
Green Lantern's were meeting with Batman
to discuss the threat and it would have
also been a major moment because Batman
had never met a Green Lantern before
he's not all about the existence of
aliens since Superman arrived in all the
Kryptonians during the events of Man of
Steel so that's not a big surprise him
meeting aliens it's just that he's never
met Green Lantern's before we actually
just found out that it was Joss Whedon
that created this post-credit scene from
the theatrical cut with Lex Luthor and
Deathstroke during his reshoots
there was a Twitter post from Joe
Manganiello implying that there was a
different version of the Deathstroke
seen in the original Snyder cut so
they'll also be adding that scene back
into the movie too
but I don't know if in that version
there were two different post credits
scenes or if the alternate Deathstroke
scene would have just happened at the
end of the movie instead of being a
proper post credits scene like the
Kilowog tomorrow a Green Lantern scene
the reason why Kilowog and tomare are
important figures in the Canon of the
Green Lantern Corps is because Kilowog
is one of the first trainers that Hal
Jordan ever had when he became a Green
Lantern and we were eventually going to
see a version of Hal Jordan Green
Lantern during the Justice League movies
in tomar Rey is important because he's
the Green
Lantern core of the sector of space
where Krypton is from so he has a
connection to Superman and knows all
about the Kryptonian culture so it has
been a really cool interaction with
those characters it's time immemorial
the Green Lantern Corps served as the
keepers of peace order and justice
throughout the universe to be chosen to
join its ranks is the highest of honors
the greatest if you're not a big Green
Lantern buff there feature prominently
during the Ryan Reynolds Green Lantern
movie if you want to dare to re-watch
that if you don't want to no worries
because obviously the versions that we
would see in the Snyder cut would be
completely different in the alternate
timeline where all the DC EU movies got
released the way that they originally
planned them they did to justice League
movies or even three the Hal Jordan the
Zack Snyder would have introduced would
have gone on to become Green Lantern and
then gone to the Green Lantern Corps
movie that we were originally supposed
to see that movie was actually supposed
to be released this year if you guys
don't remember that was part of the
original DC EU slate when they were
still doing a cyborg movie obviously
they're not doing that now they're still
doing a Green Lantern Corps movie but my
assumption is is it they'll just cast
somebody completely different so if we
see the character during the Justice
League Snyder cut that guy won't wind up
playing Green Lantern in the new Green
Lantern Corps movie whenever that winds
up getting made you're welcome Canada. they had
the Green Lantern HBO series too that'll
also privy somebody new that they cast
because it's a completely different
group of producers that's making that
show all do more videos about that when
they give us some more details about
what's going on during the DC fan dome
Comic Con panel later this summer but
then number one as for the rumors about
Sam Benjamin being Hal Jordan Green
Lantern in the movie the actor did an
interview a couple of years ago where he
talked about his deleted scene
he says the scene was part of like a 30
minute or so subplot that got completely
cut out that of course will be added
back in but he wouldn't confirm or deny
who his character was exactly he just
said that he was playing a character at
a military base that had a big scene
with a hero and a villain he wouldn't
say which hero he wouldn't say which
villain you can theorycraft
all you want about that the actor has
posted a lot of Green Lantern fan art
fans have been tweeting at him about
Green Lantern for a long time but he's
never confirmed who his character was
actually supposed to be if he was
supposed to be how Jordan or if he
just supposed to be some other regular
character but it does seem like Zack
Snyder is implied that there'll be a lot
more green lantern stuff happening
inside the Snyder cut but like I said
there are multiple different Green
Lantern's I know there are a lot of
people that are also asking about the
Justice League
rebirth movie news apparently there's a
rumor going around now that Warner
Brothers is planning on a Justice League
rebirth follow up to the first Justice
League film so it would kind of be like
a Justice League sequel but in the style
of a rebirth movie if you never read the
DC rebirth comics it's sort of like a
soft retcon without completely rebooting
everything from their pre-existing
continuity I don't know if the rumor is
true but if we get any confirmations
about that of course I'll do a new video
I think all of Warner Brothers attention
right now is going to be on the Snyder
cut and we'll learn more about that and
get more footage at the big DC fan dome
Comic Con panel in August everyone post
all your theories in the comments below
what do you think is going on with Green
Lantern during the Snyder cut
congratulations Donnie Greer you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here to learn about that
deleted scene of Michael Keaton's Batman
from crisis on Infinite Earths
and click here for the Justice League
Snyder cut trailer thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight!